most men avoid therapy because most
therapy approaches are not designed to
help the male brain deal with pain or
find solutions that makes men believe
therapy is worthless and Men skip things
that feel worthless also male depression
is usually based on feeling helpless
powerless and unable to affect one's
life or environment therapy models focus
on helping men feel heard and loved
instead of restoring their sense of
personal power men need Solutions not
just feelings absolutely and we are
churning out here in the United States
an overwhelming number of therapists who
do not have the skills that they need or
the experience that they need to provide
lasting solutions that will undiagnose
you in the long term there are not it's
not that every therapist is bad I was a
therapist for years there's many of my
colleagues who are wonderful however the
system we are doing here in America is
to desperately churn out as many Health
Care Providers as we can because we do
not have enough of them and to focus
their training in specifically on the
diagnostic and statistics manual so that
you can treat issues and then you're
going to be coupled in with all kinds of
medication and problems are not
unfixable because you're just medicating
and triaging so much of mental health in
America is based on the medical model
and endless triage endless triage
management symptom management that's all
it is for the rest of their life and
when you get a man into that system men
would rather kill themselves than sit
there and say I am disabled I must have
a medical help a medical assistance for
the rest of my life and all I can do is
sit here and talk about my feelings
endlessly for the next 10 years while
paying ten thousand dollars for the
privilege that is not what men are
looking for men are looking for
Solutions and they're looking for
guidance in how to apply those Solutions
when you give them those things men will
do just about anything for you why is a
problem why is it a problem for therapy
models to focus on helping men feel
heard and loved instead of restoring
their sense of personal power why is
that something which is uniquely male
and why is that the approach approach
that therapy models have when trying to
fix men the brain scans show us that the
male brain goes backwards to observe and
then forwards to act upon it it mostly
goes like this back observe forward act
when we see a problem we act upon that
problem that's how the male brain tends
to work the female brain tends to
observe in the back and they go back and
forth across the hemispheres and make a
bunch of connections and process it and
then think about it and and pull pieces
out and make deeper connections that
that is often why women communicate to
process with each other to share with
each other and they need to feel heard
they are also fairly risk averse
typically so a woman doesn't typically
want to be the one who makes the final
decision but they value being heard so
they can have input on a group decision
that all of them their brains go back
and forth and back and forth and make a
decision together so that there is
shared reliability and shared
responsibility among the group men want
to observe and act upon it and solve the
problem when you have a therapy model
that just makes men feel heard and loved
okay they kind of feel heard I feel
heard and they kind of feel loved well I
kind of feel loved now I I feel like a
useless piece of helpless garbage that
other people are sitting here loving
that means they just pity me and I am
just an endless creature of pity who
will never solve any problems it almost
makes them worse is there a point where
it helps men to feel hurt and loved
absolutely do men not need to feel heard
loved no they do but it just makes them
feel like they are being pitied and that
is something men would rather die than
experience for the most part you said as
well uh most therapy approaches are not
designed to help the male brain deal
with pain or find Solutions what's the
deal with painoma I can see the fine
Solutions that's the back and forth
that's that I have the information it's
time for me to enact something what
about the deal with pain thing most
women when they experience pain what
they will typically do is look for
comfort with other people look to share
that and be nurtured as they experience
the pain women are very adaptable they
are wonderfully adaptable so they endure
through the pain by building connections
and relying on those connections men
hate that when men experience pain if
they then have to go and just be a
burden to someone else they feel
worthless they would rather March off
into the Wilderness and die most
typically men need to deal with pain by
finding a way through it and finding a
purpose through it so that they can push
through that pain push through the pain
receptors push through that and follow
that mission if you do that men can go
through the pain and put it in its place
because they no longer feel helpless
against the pain there is a reason for
enduring the pain that's what men need
can you tell that story about The Blitz
in World War II again
yeah so there's research that shows
through the Blitz in World War II
psychiatric men psychiatric hospitalized
men who were comatose they would sit
there they were just miserable
wretchedly miserable but when things
started happening around them and
Society needed them when the bombs start
going off when everything happened they
were needed all of a sudden they had a
reason to get up and go do something and
that impelled them to pull out of their
pain out of their struggle out of
everything and go do what they were
supposed to do it is the same thing as a
depressed man who is finally called up
to do something and goes and does it in
his family in his life men who were who
are low and low and low and then they
find out that the woman in their life is
carrying their child and all of a sudden
it Sparks a difference in him right he
stops drinking he gets he cleans himself
up same experience I will endure the
pain for the sake of my family my
country my people my whatever it may be
here is my chance to rise up and make
this change that is what men are built
for
does the fact that a man with a strong
enough why can bear anyhow
which is a nice synopsis I guess of what
you're sort of touching on there
does this explain why Modern Men are so
insecure
that there is a massive lack of purpose
relationships around them we have more
childless men than ever we have no
intergenerational pan generational
homesteads anymore there is a lack at
least in the west of patriotism of
nationalism
um
what first off why are modern men so
insecure and then secondly how does what
we've just spoken about play into that
so many of the men who come into my
coaching program are lacking what I call
human impact they have no ability to
create human impact in their life that's
what a legacy is is the lasting human
impact that endures after your death it
does not have to be biological children
although that's one of the easiest ones
to point out and create it can be
adopted children it can be mentored
people that you help it can be people
you rescue it can be an organization
that you build a human impact is the
purpose of a man's life because someday
you will die you will be dust your money
will be fritted away and taken through
taxes and all kinds of things your
property will be divvied up yours you're
everything you've cared for in your life
will be taken away the only thing that
endures is the future Generations who
are fundamentally altered because of
your existence on this planet that is
the purpose of a man's life that is why
so many men want to kill themselves now
is because they find no purpose and no
ability to create human impact
why
would it be adaptive for a man to have
that or how do women and their life
goals and purpose differ from that
it's funny because many women and I've
worked with tons of these women they
have much the same purpose women are
much more adaptable but they want to be
useful to the people in their life and
help enhance those people's lives so
they can go out and live and Thrive
women are about helping other people
thrive men are about changing the course
of other people's life if you want to
look at it that way women can find that
purpose just about anywhere helping just
about anybody as long as they have
usefulness women can be very happy if
they are loved and feel useful to the
people that they love that's when most
women are okay and they can endure they
can crawl over broken glass but they
aren't looking for the overall
life-changing creation that men are
looking for they're looking for enduring
and helping people endure and nurture
them as they go whereas men are capable
Mission powerful
absolutely that's what men are looking
for what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]
foreign